[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débats et de
reportage on est ensemble comme tous les
soirs du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts volody
mirzuelens qui s'est rendu aujourd'hui à
Carson pour saluer le travail des
sauveteurs dans la ville sinistrée par
les inondations provoquées par
l'explosion du barrage de carrosca cette
attaque marque-t-elle un tournant dans
la guerre peut-elle retarder de
plusieurs semaines la contre-offensive
ukrainienne comment l'enquête sur ce
crime aux conséquences humaines
économiques et écologique sera menée on
répond à toutes ces questions juste
après ces titres et puis dans notre
seconde partie d'émission c'est un débat
de société que je vous propose autour
d'un pilier de nos démocraties la
liberté de la presse et puis aussi la
confiance dans les médias avec les
dérives de l'intelligence artificielle
le complotisme l'irresponsabilité des
géants d'Internet l'information sérieuse
est en danger les fausses informations
et les circule bien plus vite que le
enfin que le temps que ça prend pour
rétablir la vérité donc nous on essaie
d'aller vite et c'est vrai quand on
arrive à faire une vérification
solide qu'on publie rapidement il y a un
certain satisfaction parce que on se dit
que peut-être ça va ralentir un peu la
viralité de cette info informations la
régulation des réseaux sociaux est-elle
impossible quelle est la part de
responsabilité des journalistes dans la
défiance qu'il subissent pourquoi la
France n'est telle que 24e au classement
mondial de la liberté de la presse
beaucoup de questions passionnantes à
aborder dans 45 minutes mais d'abord on
détaille les conséquences de la
destruction du barrage de carrorska avec
Renault parquet
un peu plus de 48 heures après les
destructions du barrage de Nova kaffofka
le président Zelenski s'est rendu sur
place ce matin pour faire le point et
remercier les sauveteurs Ukrainiens
pieds d'oeuvre pour l'heure cinq
personnes auraient trouvé la mort et
plus de 5900 ont été évacués des zones
inondées 1900 par les secours ukrainiens
et plus de 4000 par les autorités
installées par Moscou une course contre
la montre humanitaire et
environnementale s'engage 600 km² de
territoire sont inondés et plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'habitants risque
de manquer d'électricité de médicaments
et d'eau potable comme ses habitants de
Kerson coincés dans leur maison et
ravitailler par un drone
le chef de l'État ukrainien a appelé la
communauté internationale les
organisations humanitaires à l'aide tout
en dénonçant le manque de réactivité des
Nations Unies et de la Croix-Rouge
s'il n'y a pas d'organisation
internationales rapidement sur place
pour faire face à cette catastrophe cela
signifie qu'elle n'existe pas et qu'elle
est incapable de fonctionner Emmanuel
Macron le président français a quant à
lui réagi hier en proposant d'envoyer de
l'aide j'ai pu dire au président
zellenski ma solidarité envers son
peuple après l'attaque du barrage de
kakovka la France condamne cet acte au
dieu qui met en danger les populations
nous enverrons dans les toutes
prochaines heures une aide pour répondre
aux besoins immédiats une dizaine de
tonnes d'équipements et de bien
humanitaires d'urgence permettant de
purifier l'eau envoyer par Paris
arriveront sur place dans les prochaines
heures car derrière la crise sanitaire
une crise environnementale se joue 150
tonnes d'huile de machine sont venus
polluer les eaux du Nièvre la faune et
la flore sont impactées et déjà des
tonnes de poissons sont morts d'asphyxie
un acte que dénonce le président
ukrainien accusant directement les tarus
dans une vidéo postée hier sur les
réseaux sociaux
sont commis le plus grand crime
d’ecocytes sur le territoire ukrainien
non seulement au cours de cette guerre
mais aussi depuis des décennies ils
l'ont fait intentionnellement
premièrement pour faire chanter le monde
entier deuxièmement pour faire sauter le
barrage et utiliser l'inondation comme
une arme la réponse russe ne s'est pas
faite à tendre devant la Cour
internationale de justice par la voix de
l'un de ses diplomates Russie et Ukraine
se renvoyant infote en fait c'est
l'Ukraine qu'il a fait le régime de Kiev
a non seulement lancé des attaques
d'artillerie massives contre le barrage
dans la nuit du 6 juin mais il a aussi
délibérément porter le niveau d'eau du
réservoir de kakovka un niveau critique
en ouvrant les vannes de la centrale
hydroélectrique de demi-provski au
niveau international les réactions
demeurent prudentes les États-Unis la
Grande-Bretagne et la Chine même refuse
distribuer la responsabilité d'un tel
acte en revanche il se disent très
préoccupé par les conséquences
économiques humanitaires et
environnementales et on va en débattre
tout de suite de ces conséquences avec
Mariana Perret vesio bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste franco-ukrainienne
ou collaboré à l'hebdomadaire
ukrainskitis den et aux médias des
Russie Julie interromptoir enseignant en
conflit et sécurité international à
Sciences Po et co-auteur de ce livre Le
Pacte des autocrates chez Robert Lafont
Mathilde Philippe grève bonsoir ok
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur de droit public à
l'Université Jean Moulin de Lyon auteur
de ce livre peut-on juger Poutine il
vient de sortir aux éditions Albin
Michel j'accueille également avec nous
en duplex Pierre-Alain nazique et
président de géodynamique et structure
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes également directeur
du master spécialisé génie civil des
grands ouvrages pour l'énergie à l'École
des Ponts ParisTech et Centrale Paris et
ancien président du comité scientifique
qui est technique de l'association
française du génie parasismique on
attend votre expertise avec intérêt et
Laetitia cruppa éditoris politique
bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue à vous mais
on n'attend pas moins votre expertise
Mariana Pyrénées si on va commencer par
rappeler où on se situe dans quel zone
de guerre et ce barrage et qui le
contrôlait ça aussi je pense que c'est
important de le redire alors nous nous
situons ensuite de l'Ukraine donc cela
où le fleuve ni pro se jette dans la mer
Noire
un amont de la ville de Kerson il y
avait un il y avait une importante
retenue d'eau qui était utilisée jusqu'à
présent pour des divers besoins pour les
besoins de la population civile en tant
qu'aupotable pour l'agriculture toute
quasiment toute l'agriculture de la
région des régions environnantes en
dépendent
c'était également le barrage qui
produisait de l'électricité pour des
millions d'Ukrainiens et qui vivaient
dans dans les régions aux alentours et
cette centrale cette centrale
hydroélectrique ce barrage a été
occupé tout au début de de l'invasion
russe en
fin février 2020 il tient en avait le
contrôle et ils avaient encore le
contrôle de ce barrage les Russes
ils ont toujours le contrôle sur les
ruines
interrompre parce qu'on va peut-être
tout de suite balayer les arguments
russes qui accusent l'artillerie
ukrainienne dans cette dans cette
affaire je vais vous poser une question
qui est peut-être agaçante mais quel
intérêt l'Ukraine aurait eu à bombarder
ce cette infrastructure ce barrage
elle est pas si agaçante mais il faut la
poser déjà parce que c'est le travail
des journalistes et des chercheurs
d'établir les faits mais effectivement
on sèche un peu de savoir quel serait
l'intérêt des Ukrainiens comme vous
l'indiquiez déjà l'Ukraine n'attaque pas
les Ukrainiens puisque les Ukrainiens
résiste une agression extérieure la
Russie n'a rien à faire ni sur ce
barrage ni sur le territoire souverain
de l'Ukraine donc on voit mal pourquoi
l'Ukraine détruirait ses propres moyens
de production électrique provoquerait
une crise environnementale d'ailleurs
juste en amont d'un parc national
également privé des ses habitants
d'électricité et de conditions de vie
enfin je vais il y a assez peu de
dimensions rationnelles là dedans quant
au point de vue militaire il y a assez
peu d'intérêt en réalité c'était un
point de passage potentiel pour des
blindés le barrage lui-même qui est donc
supprimé et surtout ça allonge
considérablement la distance fluviale à
traverser en aval du barrage pour passer
de l'autre côté
on sait que l'offensive de printemps si
elle est lancée elle n'est pas que dans
cette région il y a beaucoup de points
d'attaque mais en l'occurrence c'était
une des possibilités pour attaquer la
Crimée par exemple on y reviendra
évidemment sur les conséquences sur le
l'offensive ou la contre-offensive
va-t-il faire vous vous appelez avec
d'autres juristes d'autres
universitaires des chercheurs à la
création d'un tribunal spécial pour
juger les crimes d'agression de manière
Poutine en Ukraine sur cette sur ce fait
précis j'essaye de me mettre à la place
d'enquêteurs enfin c'est le travail
d'enquête il va être
ultra compliqué il ne peut pas commencer
aujourd'hui puisque sont toujours les
Russes qui tiennent cette zone comment
ça peut se passer alors en réalité si il
commence aujourd'hui avec le les vidéos
qui sont actuellement qui viennent des
deux côtés avec les relais satellites
enfin il y a quand même des moyens de de
retrouver des preuves il y aura des
témoignages des personnes qui sont sur
place donc l'enquête commence
aujourd'hui et vous parliez du crime
d'agression tout à l'heure ce crime
d'agression que l'on veut absolument
voir juger le crime d'agression en fait
c'est le fait de déclencher une guerre
illégale et c'est ce qui entraîne tous
les autres crimes sans le crime
d'agression vous n'avez pas de crime
contre l'humanité de crime de guerre
voire de crimes de génocide sans le
crime d'agression vous n'avez pas de
viol vous n'avez pas de destruction de
musée vous n'avez pas d'enfants tués ou
de torture le crime d'agression c'est le
crime originel donc il faut commencer
par qualifier ce crime et d'ailleurs on
va
ensuite on abordera d'autres questions
notamment la question de
d'écocide parce que c'est une nouvelle
notion en droit mais mais où en est la
communauté internationale comme
juridique internationale sur l'hypothèse
de créer un tribunal spécial pour juger
ce criminel nous avons bonne espoir tous
ceux qui militons pour cette juridiction
quel aboutissent puisque le 1er juillet
prochain devrait être créé un centre de
poursuite pour pouvoir commencer
justement à réfléchir à l'émission d'un
mandat d'arrêt pour ce crime d'agression
donc des négociations sont actuellement
en cours participent les principaux
États européens de l'Union européenne le
Conseil de l'Europe les États-Unis la
Grande-Bretagne donc nous avons bon
espoir que cela puisse aboutir et autant
de temps pourquoi le premier juillet
alors en réalité pour nous c'est très
rapide pour les juristes puisque la
guerre a été déclenchée quand même il y
a moins enfin il y a un petit peu plus
d'un an et surtout le conflit n'est pas
terminé donc c'est extrêmement rapide
pour des juristes et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir encore accélérer pour avoir
quand même un jugement pour ce crime
d'agression alors je reviens aux
conditions de de destruction du barrage
écoutez Scandi le président ukrainien
il est physiquement impossible de faire
sauter le barrage d'une manière ou d'une
autre de l'extérieur avec des
bombardements il a été miné il a été
miné par les occupants russes qui l'ont
fait exploser alors je me tourne une
première fois vers vous pierre-allemazy
ce barrage il fait 16 mètres de haut il
mesure près de 4 km à 3850 mètres une
installation de cette taille c'est
conçue pour résister à quoi
alors le barrage qui mesure plus de 3 km
de long comme vous venez de dire il est
fait en enrochement de part et d'autre
de la partie centrale qui a été
dynamité et c'est cette partie en béton
très solide massive qui reçoit les
organes de ventellerie qui permettent
aux vannes de
s'ouvrir ou de se fermer pour contrôler
l'eau qui a été détruite donc c'est la
partie la plus
la plus la plus importante du barrage
celle qui supporte les organes de
sécurité qui a été détruite et ce que je
viens de dire le président selinski est
plutôt juste moi je partage cet avis on
essaye parfois
il y a eu des précédents dans dans des
guerres en Europe pour regarder comment
on faisait pour détruire des barrages il
faut des quantités considérables
d'explosifs pour détruire un barrage
comme celui-ci c'est extrêmement
compliqué de le détruire à travers des
des tirs de l'extérieur et très
probablement c'est bien ceux qui au
moment où l'explosion a eu lieu contrôlé
ce barrage qui l'ont détruit
volontairement ne serait-ce que quand on
voit la précision des des de la
destruction qui concernent juste la
partie qui convenait de détruire pour
générer une inondation
meurtrière le barrage est utilisé ici
comme une arme c'est classique c'est
traditionnel ça a été fait depuis des
milliers d'années on l'a vu en 2014 avec
un menace de l'État islamique sur le
barrage de Mossoul on l'a vu pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale sur les barrages
de la roue qui ont été détruits et
bombardé on l'a vu en 1941 sur un
barrage sur le même fleuve
détruit par l'armée rouge et qui avait
fait plus de 10000 morts donc c'est
classique et on inonde les zones et qui
sont protégées par les barrages le jour
où on veut transformer le barrage en une
arme voilà merci
des complications que ça peut causer
puisque les barrages sont aussi des
voies de communication donc pour les
routes pour pour le rail ça a été
détruit au début la guerre donc les
Russes ont réglées le problème de votre
communication au début de la guerre en
novembre ils avaient déjà bombardé ça
sur le barrage mais sans le détruire et
puis comme on l'a dit on prive la
l'Ukraine de 375 mégawatts c'est le
tiers d'une centrale nucléaire on prive
l'Ukraine de l'irrigation d'une zone
assez importante puisque c'est un
barrage qui sert aussi à l'irrigation
puis à la navigation également on peut
remonter descendre en aval de ce barrage
alors ce qui est effectivement je vous
interrompre rien je reviendrai vers vous
et évidemment d'autres fois pendant ce
débat ce que j'entends Mariana pibition
c'est que la destruction de ce barrage
elle était peut-être prévie enfin
prévisible ou en tout cas ça faisait
partie des craintes des Ukrainiens ça a
été exprimé plusieurs fois ça tout à
fait déjà il y a six mois
courant l'automne l'hiver le président
Zelinski lui en personne et le prévenait
qui ce risque existe mais par ailleurs
tous les Ukrainiens ils savaient que ce
risque existait dès le moment où le
barrage
pourrait trouver sous le contrôle de
l'armée russe c'est pour ça qu'on
appelait dès le départ à ce qui est un
contrôle international sur ces ouvrages
et sur les centrales
électriques
ensuite votre expert il a mentionné à
juste titre à une autre tragédie qui a
déjà eu lieu à nous
1941 quand l'armée rouge a fait sauter
en barrage ni progrès asaporijah
c'était un tuant des milliers de
citoyens soviétiques sont les prévenir
sans les évacuer
c'était un crime de plus contre la
population ukrainienne c'est comme ça
que c'est comme ça que c'est perçu à
l'Ukraine que ça a toujours été
persuadéienne
il faut aussi savoir que il était de
l'époque soviétique il était interdit de
parler de ce crime c'était un crime
interdite à bouée on a commencé à parler
de
on a commencé à parler des morts et des
destructions environ à 89 voir 90 c'est
pour ça même qu'aujourd'hui encore il y
a un doute qui persiste sur le nombre
exact de victimes mais on sait que c'est
enfin le nombre de ses victimes s'élève
certainement à plusieurs milliers voire
plusieurs dizaines de milliers ce sont
les estimations plus ou moins
prudentes c'est une grande très c'est un
grand traumatisme pour les ukrainiens et
se réveille là
qui est réactivé si vous voulez il n'y a
pas que les crimes commis par l'armée
russe par les Russes à l'Ukraine en 2022
il y a tout un très long historique de
crimes de masse des génocides commis à
l'Ukraine par les Russes par les
Soviétiques a commencé par le plus grand
au lot de mort mais ça a été aussi
ponctué par tout un nombre de crimes
plus petits de massacres plus aussi voir
de pour une fois ce n'était pas voulu la
catastrophe des Tchernobyl pareil
c'était un très grand traumatisme pour
les ukrainiens et pour les biélorusses
qui ont supporté vraiment le poids de
ces catastrophes là c'est intéressant
parce que ça ajoute un argument dans le
le l'hypothèse que ce soit un acte
stratégique des Russes quoi c'est je me
tourne vers vous Julien Theron pour
aller un peu plus loin sur ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure
sur la contre-offensive donc
elle passait enfin d'abord on savait pas
forcément par où ça allait passer il y a
plusieurs zones possibles on l'a bien
compris mais dans cette partie là du
territoire
ukrainien ça retarde une est-ce que
c'est impossible de mener une offensive
aujourd'hui avec cette quantité d'eau
voilà comment je peux poser la question
sur place oui pour plusieurs raisons je
me permets juste de faire un une petite
un petit ajout parce qu'effectivement il
y a une quasiment une analogie
historique aussi puisque les forces
russes qui procèdent aux évacuations
cotées donc est du fleuve font supprimer
les images de de téléphone portable aux
populations civiles ce qui en gros un
peu cette idée quand on ne peut pas en
parler quand même box soviétique les
mêmes mécanismes le tabou qui avait tenu
jusque dans les années 90 voilà il
essaie de le recréer une certaine façon
en tout cas de contrôler l'information
du point de vue militaire effectivement
c'était c'était un emplacement
stratégique en fait il y a quelques mois
les forces ukrainiennes dans leur
progression
vers Herson ont aussi essayé de faire un
espèce de crochet par le nord et on se
rapprochant de Nova carrosca justement
pour à mon avis enfin c'est comme ça je
l'interprété de pouvoir se servir du
barrage pour faire passer des troupes et
reprendre le contrôle de cette
infrastructure
c'était très pertinent et j'avais bien
compris que deux buts étaient possibles
à partir de là c'était de foncer à l'est
vers melitopol qui est une grosse poche
de résistance antirrus local et
potentiellement au sud vers la Crimée
donc c'était un des points de passage ça
me paraissait dès que j'ai entendu la
nouvelle je j'évite compris l'intérêt
stratégique de du barrage alors
complètement fou parce que quand on vous
écoute vous madame vous monsieur vous
saviez les Ukrainiens pouvaient le
prédire la communauté internationale
aussi vous vous-même vous l'avez prédit
et finalement on a laissé faire on n'a
rien pu empêcher on a des moyens limités
contrôlaient la zone effectivement
c'était plus compliqué parmi les
conséquences de la destruction de de ce
barrage il y a les risques de
contamination par les mines et les
explosifs déplacés sur ce thème je vous
propose d'écouter Martin grichit ce qui
est un responsable de l'ONU pour les
affaires d'humanitaires
il s'agit d'un coup dur pour un secteur
de production alimentaire qui comme nous
le savons est déjà fortement endommagé
nous sommes également particulièrement
préoccupés par les risques explosifs des
mines et des munitions car les eaux en
mouvement rapide déplacent les
projectiles vers des zones auparavant
considé rées comme sur cela expose les
personnes à des dangers supplémentaires
et imprévisibles je voudrais qu'on se
penche effectivement sur les
conséquences de ce de la destruction de
ce barrage pierre à la nazi je reviens
vers vous est-ce qu'on peut comparer le
barrage de carrouska à un barrage
français en taille en voilà en quantité
d'eau et puis surtout comment l'eau se
déverse est-ce que c'est brutal est-ce
que c'est progressif comment ça se passe
alors dans le cas du barrage kakova on a
affaire à une retenue en amont de ce
barrage de 18 millions de mètres cubes
c'est considérable vraiment considérable
et la manière dont se barrage a été
détruit je vous l'ai dit
bon suggère que on a on a miné très
probablement de l'intérieur le barrage
au niveau des organes de contrôle de
l'hôtellerie c'est-à-dire les vannes qui
s'ouvrent et qui se referment et il faut
pour ça détruire toutes les structures
supports de ces de ces vagues qui sont
dans un très gros béton et on l'a dit
effectivement c'est sans doute de
l'intérieur ça a été détruit une fois
que on a détruit ça on maîtrise plus
donc le flow
le débit d'eau qu'on peut relâcher ou
pas soit pour les besoins en irrigation
en soi pour éviter les inondations parce
que les barrages ont un rôle de maîtrise
des inondations soit pour produire du
courant et on a un déversement à la
positif dans le cas de ce barrage parce
qu'on n'est pas dans le cas par exemple
du barrage de mal passé qui était un
barrage voûte très fin dans le sud de la
France qui a rompu brutalement et qui
relâcher tout le réservoir d'eau comme
une énorme vague et en quelques minutes
on a eu 400 morts c'est pas le cas ici
vous avez comme submersion de ce barrage
et plus aucun contrôle sur le libido et
on sait donc progressivement on peut
prédire la zone qui va être inondée
suite à des façons de ce barrage il faut
rajouter ça a été très bien votre
portage que très probablement cette
inondation
donc
intentionnelle utiliser comme une arme a
été maximisée par l'envie de remplir le
barrage à son niveau quasiment maximum
juste avant de le faire sauter on peut
rappeler qu'en novembre il était très
bas le niveau de ce barrage on a les
relevés il était très bas comme ça ça
permet d'éviter en tout cas de réduire
les dizaines présentation en eau potable
on irrigation pour ceux qui en ont
besoin et puis on la fait remonter
volontairement au mois de mai à son
maximum juste avant de faire sauter pour
maximiser l'inondation alors ce sont des
nations classiques comme on aurait si le
fleuve ni être débordait voilà alors
c'est catastrophique pour
l'environnement pour les habitations
parce que forcément depuis qu'elle se
barrage les villes ont colonisé les
abords du Nièvre qui était donc été par
ce barrage et là aujourd'hui on a
quelque chose qui échappe complètement à
tout contre ce qu'on voit à l'image
notamment vous faisiez donc c'est pas
une vague comme mal passé mal passé 1959
423 morts à Fréjus et dans et dans sa
région un mot de j'ai interrompre des
mines ou des explosifs dans d'en parler
le responsable de l'ONU bon c'est
évidemment d'abord dangereux pour les
responsables de la région mais en
entendant ça je me dis est-ce que c'est
est-ce que ça complique aussi je reviens
à la contre-offensive est-ce que ça peut
compliquer aussi
l'action de militaire le fait que des
mines étaient comme ça dép par les flots
oui bien sûr c'est aléatoire mais en
l'occurrence ça complique les choses
mais de toute façon pour être
raisonnable au regard de la zone inondée
ça devient parfaitement impossible parce
qu'on passe dans la zone même avec des
engins etc alors on des engins en fibi à
ma connaissance l'Ukraine n'en a pas ça
règlement en fait pour la petite
histoire la MX10 que les Français ont
donné vous savez c'est c'est blindé à
roux mais avec une tourelle de tank une
version amphibie existait mais on n'est
pas sûr que ce soit la version et de
toute façon on en a pas donné
suffisamment pour faire une offensive
majeure dans cette dans cette région il
y a d'autres possibilités comme des
ponts flottants ou des bacs mais en
réalité vu la zone couverte c'est
absolument considérable plus le courant
c'est aussi une dimension comme le
disait Pierre-Anne à Nazé effectivement
c'est un débit continu donc ça veut dire
que ça peut être potentiellement
changeant c'est une rivière qui reprend
plus ou moins son lit et qui n'a pas du
tout de de structure permanente donc ça
joue bien sûr et il est est devenu
quasiment impossible de faire passer des
blindés par là alors on a à l'instant un
urgent qui nous vient de de l'Agence
France Presse qui nous dit que le
réservoir d'eau du barrage ne suffit
plus à refroidir les réacteurs de la
centrale nucléaire de zapporica alors
c'était l'une des craintes je vous vois
réagir Marina parce que voilà c'était
alors la centrale elle est à 150 km donc
alors de prime abord quand on est comme
moi un peu bio aussi on se dit bah
pourquoi c'est lié donc il faut
expliquer l'eau de ce barrage et le
servait à la centrale c'est ça mais
exactement enfin le retenu en tous les
cas enfin je pense que ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça et vous aurez tout à
l'heure l'occasion des questionner notre
expert l'ingénieur qui nous renseignera
sans doute mieux enfin c'est tout un
système hydraulique mais effectivement
ça servait la centrale également ce qui
est un élément non négligeable nous ne
revenons toujours voyez vers
le fait que à l'heure où nous parlons
malheureusement nous ne pouvons même pas
dresser et ce qui c'est les contours
exacts de toutes les conséquences de
cette catastrophe que nous connaissons
d'ores et déjà immenses que nous
connaissons déjà
d'ores et déjà duré duré pendant des des
années y avoir des conséquences
maintenant c'est vrai que la centrale
des aporisa reste une inquiétude numéro
1 et par ailleurs pour revenir à la
question nous sur la centrale sur la
centrale hydraulique sur le barrage nous
savions nous n'avons rien fait il est
encore temps de faire quelque chose par
exemple pour la centrale des aporadies
il y a encore temps justement est-ce que
on peut envoyer les Occidentaux peuvent
t'envoyer non mais alors c'est à
discuter c'est à discuter mais il faut
commencer à poser la question très très
clairement et de manière intransigeante
au niveau de la communauté
internationale que maintenant les
organismes internationaux compétents
doivent prendre le contrôle entier de la
centrale sinon il y a l'embargo total
sur la Russie dans trois jours par
exemple est-ce que c'est possible c'est
possible
vous voyez c'est une c'est une piste il
faut la volonté politique pour cela
aussi il me semble mais alors on est
plus exactement là pour l'instant on
fournit des armes aux Ukrainiens c'est
plus tout à fait la même la même
dimension
géopolitique et même juridique alors on
pourrait imaginer une intervention non
pas des Occidentaux mais de la
communauté internationale à travers
l'organisation des Nations Unies si la
Russie veut démontrer sa bonne volonté
il faudrait qu'elle évite de bloquer une
résolution du Conseil de sécurité qui
pourrait envisager une opération de
maintien en l'état de la sécurité autour
de la centrale nucléaire la centrale
alors ça n'atteignerait pas la
responsabilité des uns et des autres ou
des États concernés mais au moins cela
pourrait montrer la bonne volonté et de
la Russie si jamais elle voulait le
faire elle peut le faire donc il
faudrait plutôt envisager cela une
opération de la communauté
internationale voilà mais c'est tout à
l'heure on parlait là des des images qui
sont en train de disparaître et
peut-être que là aussi il y a des
preuves qui vont commencer à disparaître
l'idée de faire disparaître des preuves
parce que la Russie c'est très bien que
la justice va passer la justice pénale
internationale va passer et donc si elle
veut atténuer aussi la responsabilité
alors non seulement de l'état de l'État
russe mais aussi de ses dirigeants il va
falloir qu'elle montre un peu de bonne
volonté alors un témoignage
autour du risque lié à la centrale de
vaporica Denis toutes sayev qui est
chargée de campagne de Greenpeace pour
l'Europe centrale et orientale on
l'écoute en ce qui concerne les
conséquences pour la centrale nucléaire
nous pouvons comparer le pire scénario à
celui de Fukushima en 2011 où il y avait
une fusion du cœur de l'un des réacteurs
si le pire se produit à la centrale
nucléaire de zapporizia les chercheurs
de Greenpeace estiment que des centaines
de kilomètres de terre pourrait ne plus
être habitable pendant les prochaines
décennies Julien Theron a un mot rapide
pour boucler ce petit chapitre consacré
à la centrale nucléaire on l'a déjà dit
sur ce plateau c'est aussi une carte
dans la menace
de Vladimir Poutine il sait en usé
veut dire oui le la guerre contemporaine
ne se fait pas uniquement avec des armes
traditionnelles ça se fait aussi au
travers des esprits ça se fait au
travers aussi des infrastructures
civiles les Russes démontrent largement
les bombardants ça se fait aussi en
produisant des effets à conséquence ça
soit aussi en faisant diverger
l'attention comme c'était très bien dit
c'est à dire que on ne s'occupe plus
vraiment des opérations militaires en
fait dans les relations internationales
vous avez toujours des narrations des
sujets à l'agenda et là le sujet c'est
le barrage la centrale le sujet c'est
plus les 16 vous voyez ce que je veux
dire bien sûr on peut pas parler tout
tout le temps tous ensemble donc si on
parle de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui on parle
de ça on ne parle plus des F16 et
pourtant c'est le meilleur moyen
d'éviter ce genre de débattre c'est de
continuer le soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine un mot rapide s'il vous plaît
Pierre-Alain Nazé parce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder dans dans
ce débat le lien je voulais vous
entendre quand même sur le lien entre
effectivement le barrage qui vient
d'être détruit et la centrale nucléaire
oui merci alors deux mots là-dessus je
suis un peu surpris par l'information
qui vient d'être donné parce que la
centrale des aporisa est arrêtée depuis
déjà très longtemps et quand on arrête
une centrale nucléaire en quelques
secondes on évacue 90% de la puissance
dans ce barrage il reste ensuite pendant
quelques mois la nécessité d'évacuer ce
qu'on appelle la puissance résiduelle
alors vu que ça fait très longtemps
qu'elle est arrêté je vois pas trop ce
qui risque d'arriver encore assez de ça
pourrait déjà ça c'est important de le
savoir ensuite quand on regarde le
niveau d'eau le réservoir pardon je vous
interrompre je redonne l'info pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent c'est l'opérateur de
la centrale voilà la source c'est
l'Agence France Presse qui donne
l'information et je le lis du premier au
dernier mot Ukraine deux points le
réservoir d'eau du barrage ne s'y fuient
plus à refroidir les réacteurs de la
centrale nucléaire vous comme les
lisez cette phrase que vous entendez
cette phrase vous la comprenez pas bien
très bien bah c'est important je sais
bien qu'il faut ils ont assez d'eau pour
tourner en canard comme très longtemps
et et évacuer le pionce visuelle donc je
suis un peu surpris mais on pourrait
avoir des surprises quand même si j'ai
pas toutes les informations donc ça me
surprend un petit peu deuxième chose on
a dit tout à l'heure que on savait on
aurait dû protéger le barrage on sait
aussi pour la centrale vapory Jack elle
est très exposée on devrait la protéger
il y a aujourd'hui dans les textes
internationaux et l'ONU protège les
centrales nucléaires et les barrages je
dis bien et les barrages et on n'aurait
pas dû laisser faire ce qui s'est fait
ce qui s'est passé sur les barrages
comme on devrait pas laisser faire ce
qui se passe sur les aporis déjà il y a
le corpus réglementaire national qui
interdit d'utiliser les centrales
nucléaires et les barrages comme armes
comme ça a été fait là pour le pour le
barrage et peut-être
ce qui s'annonce pour ça pour réduire
donc ça c'est parfaitement interdit dans
les lois internationales les centrales
nucléaires sont protégées par ces lois
internationales en cas de guerre et les
barrages aussi merci de de ces
précisions je propose à Jonathan du
priez de nous rejoindre parce qu'il y a
un mot qu'on entend beaucoup depuis deux
jours c'est le mot écocide bonsoir
Jonathan là c'est entre la destruction
de ce barrage elle relance le sujet de
l'impact environnemental de la guerre et
de chaque plus lourd en Ukraine oui vous
l'avez peut-être entendu il y a eu ce
cri d'alarme lancé par les experts et
les associations environnementales qui
assurent que c'est 18 milliards de
tonnes d'eau qui ont été déversés et
bien elles auront des conséquences sans
précédent en Ukraine d'abord en altérant
durablement les écosystèmes du fleuve
Dieppe jusqu'aux zones côtières de la
mer Noire et entraînant aussi au passage
une mortalité massive de poissons de
mollusques de végétaux et de rongeurs
qui vivaient aux abords de ce cours
d'eau il y a aussi plusieurs vous l'avez
abordé plusieurs parcs nationaux classés
à l'Unesco qui sont menacés de graves
pollution notamment dues aux ordures et
aux hydrocarbures donc c'est un désastre
écologique qui va mettre des années
avant de se résorber selon les
associations à écouter
selon les estimations des scientifiques
il faudra entre 3 et 10 ans pour que les
différentes espèces se régénèrent si
tentait qu'elles puissent le faire car
il est probable que certaines espèces ne
parviennent pas à se remettre comme
avant ni à se remettre tout court
et donc ça pose cette question
d'éventuelles sanctions la Russie
pourrait-elle être condamnée pour crime
d'Écaussinnes alors je vais simplement
et qu'aussi pour les gens qui nous
regardent c'est un terme qui désigne une
destruction massive et durable de
l'Environnement il y a aussi le
caractère irrémédiable de ces
destructions ça c'est très important
pour en revenir au barrage
Ukraine et Russie et vous le disiez se
renvoie la balle pour le moment de la
responsabilité de la destruction de ce
barrage mais si une responsabilité russe
venait à être établie mais en fait il y
aurait pas grand chose qui pourrait se
passer parce qu'en droit international
le crime d'écossie des biens n'existe
pas il ne régit par aucun texte même la
Cour pénale internationale et je parle
sous votre contrôle ne dispose pas d'un
tel arsenal dans les quatre typologies
de crimes qu'elle peut juger et de toute
de toute façon la Cour pénale
internationale ne peut pas juger des
États mais ne juge que des individus
donc la seule avancée notable qu'on peut
noter c'est que fin mars l'Union
européenne a ouvert la voie à la
reconnaissance de ce crime d'écocide
dans le droit communautaire mais il
faudra ensuite négocier avec les 27
États membres et ça ça va prendre du
temps et est-ce qu'il y a des états
ailleurs sur la planète qui ont déjà
inscrit ce crime d'écossil dans leur
dans leur droit national oui celui qui
est le plus emblématique on peut le
citer c'est le Vietnam et on peut très
vite aussi comprendre pourquoi en 1990
le pays inscrit dans son code pénal le
crime d'écocide et bah ce pays il a été
aussi ravagé par 20 ans de guerre en
s'en souvient de 55 à 75 et ravagé
surtout par l'usage par l'armée
américaine de l'agent orange un défaut
liant très puissant qui a provoqué à la
fois un désastre environnemental mais
aussi un désastre humain et si on se
rapproche un peu plus de notre histoire
récente et bien ici même au Sénat des
socialistes ont tenté d'inscrire le
crime d'écocide dans notre droit pénal
et ça c'était en 2019 mais ça a été
retoqué au Palais du Luxembourg merci
beaucoup Jonathan pour pour toutes ces
informations évidemment je me ne vers
vous Mathilde Fenouillet cette notion
d'écocide effectivement pour l'instant
elle est nouvelle pas encore inscrite
dans le droit international c'est en
cours il y a des discussions oui oui
c'est en cours et puis alors je vais
compléter ce qui a été dit nous ne
sommes pas démunis au niveau juridique
pour pouvoir poursuivre ce qui s'est
passé ce qui est arrivé avant-hier c'est
un crime de guerre donc depuis en fait
un crime de guerre c'est un crime qui
est commis dans le cadre de la guerre et
en lien avec cette guerre et donc un
crime de guerre et défini non seulement
par des conventions internationales mais
aussi par les lois et coutume de la
guerre et alors ironie de l'histoire
auquel les Russes ont largement
contribué Nicolas II mais aussi le
juriste de Mertens qui a contribué à
humaniser la guerre et à faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des crimes de guerre donc
parmi ces crimes de guerre il y a
traditionnellement le fait de s'attaquer
à des infrastructures qui produisent de
l'électricité et telle que les barrages
tels que les centrales nucléaires donc
ça fait partie des crimes de guerre qui
seront pour y avoir il y aura sans doute
poursuites pour cet acte particulier
mais on n'est pas dans l'impact
environnemental c'est ça que je veux
dire pas encore si on pourra le relier
d'accord on avait également les
destructions et puis la teinte aux
populations civile non proportionnée non
justifiés stratégiquement si vous voulez
c'est aussi un crime de guerre et là le
fait de noyer l'environnement c'est non
seulement dommageable pour
l'environnement mais aussi pour les
populations civiles alors l'écocine en
fait c'est un peu particulier
l'écossiles a pour objectif
d'autonomiser la notion par rapport au
crime de guerre pour que ce soit
punissable en temps de paix comme en
temps de guerre donc c'est ça l'avantage
et puis l'avantage aussi c'est de
montrer son importance pour le futur et
moi j'ai très bon espoir que ce soit
bientôt dans le statut de la Cour pénale
internationale on a des juristes
notamment des juristes français qui
travaillent à la définition de ce crime
qui ont défini ce crime en 2021 le
Parlement de l'Union européenne
effectivement à plaider pour que ce
crime soit inscrit dans le droit de
l'Union européenne je pense qu'on va y
parvenir donc on a l'arsenal il faut
vraiment le savoir là l'idée ce serait
d'autonomiser ce client un mot Mariana
périmésique sur le sur cette région là
la faune la flore la richesse
environnemental en quelque sorte de
cette région qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire et bien en effet ça a été déjà
mentionné c'est ça une nature assez
unique ça ça accueille plusieurs parcs
naturels il y a eu des déserts de
paysages naturels désertiques des
paysages naturels du marécage protégés
il y avait la fleur et la faune qui
n'existe que dans cette partie de
l'Ukraine par ailleurs ça aussi là c'est
un crime massif parce que il y a
énormément d'animaux qui vont mourir à
la fois d'ailleurs dès les premières
heures ce sont tous les animaux du zoo
de novakarufka qui sont morts noyés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été évacués donc
voyez après c'est c'est quand même un
acte de torture de barbarie envers les
animaux même si ce ne sont pas des
animaux forcément protégés quoi que dans
la région il se peut qu'il y ait des
animaux vraiment locaux nous ne savons
pas à l'heure actuelle ce qui va arriver
avec ces écosystèmes nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer c'est vrai que
on a quand même quelques prévisions sur
ce qui peut se passer quand on attendra
le point maximum 2 comme dos comment ça
va commencer à se retirer mais la
réalité est aussi c'est que tout ça
reste approximatif il faudra attendre
vraiment quelques jours pour voir là où
se stabilisera réellement l'eau et là ça
risque également de
d'endommager également les écosystèmes
en amont également parce qu'il manquera
l'eau il y aura le poisson qui mourra
par manque d'eau il y aura des animaux
aquatiques qui m'auront par manque d'eau
en amont voyez donc là vraiment c'est
l'écossais je ne sais pas si nous
parlons du crime mais la notion
d'écossiles
la destruction de tout un écosystème
ukrainien
qui fait partie aussi de la culture de
mentalité de l'identité nationale c'est
même là où ça s'inscrit quelque part
dans dans l'idée du génocide si vous
voyez parce que ces paysages cette
nature ces animaux ils font partie de la
culture d'identité de du folklore
de des habitudes et on détruit
cette identité on va ouvrir un tout
dernier chapitre dans ce débat il nous
reste autour de 5 minutes Laetitia on va
on va parler de la on va se concentrer
un peu plus sur la Russie parce que on
s'est posé plusieurs fois sur ce plateau
la question de la
fragilisation éventuelle du régime de
Vladimir Poutine il y a quelques voix
qui commence à en parler dans la façon
française et puis c'est vrai que nous ça
nous intéresse parce que nous les
occidentaux ça reste quand même un
système complètement opaque pour nous
alors j'ai relevé pour vous deux
interviews intéressants dans la presse
cette semaine dans Franck tireur et dans
l'Express d'enfant tireur c'est celle de
l'essayer c'est d'ailleurs à Karman
qu'on venait ici du crypte le système
Poutine elle aussi entendir depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'effectivement il y
aurait des guerres intestines à
l'intérieur du Kremlin mais elle Gaïa
Karman défend la thèse que non c'est
Vladimir Poutine qui reste le grand
manipulateur tout-puissant et qui
manipule les uns et les autres dans son
propre intérêt notamment on en a parlé
beaucoup aussi le chef de la miss W
trigogine qui laisse critiquer le
système dans les médias d'ailleurs
nationaux ils le laissent faire parce
que ça lui permettrait de se venger un
peu de du chef des armées et puis du
ministre de la défense qu'il jugerait
une efficace alors ce qui est ce qu'on a
moins dit et je trouve que c'est
vraiment intéressant d'autres
observateurs prétendent que la société
russe est plus divisée qu'on ne
l'imagine oui c'est une interview dans
l'Express d'André yakoflay c'est un
professeur d'université russe qui
enseigne à Harvard et alors lui affirme
qu'à ses yeux la Russie est déjà en
guerre civile une guerre civile qui
serait comparable toujours selon lui
bien sûr
à celle qui a déchiré le pays entre 1917
et 1921 alors pourquoi c'est quoi ça
démonstration parce que les ministres
armés prolifèrent alors on connaît
Wagner mais il y a énormément d'autres
milices qui sont créés jour après jour
par des groupes publics comme guessprom
mais aussi par des entreprises privées
et donc il y a comme ça une ambiance de
chaos selon lui dans les grandes villes
de Russie avec un autre phénomène les
combattants les anciens combattants qui
reviennent qui reviennent du des combats
justement et qui sème le trouble qui
sont très agressifs en ville et qui
elles font planer comme ça une menace
qui peut surgir à tout moment et qui
donc
pourrait dire qu'il y a un ce climat ce
climat de guerre civile et qui dit il
dit guerre civile froide c'est ça le
terme qu'il emplois parce que pour le
moment il dit que la société russe n'a
jamais été aussi divisée et que les
oligares commencent à se retourner même
contre le pouvoir pourquoi il dit cela
parce qu'en Russie sur les réseaux
sociaux ont fuité plusieurs je ne sais
pas si vous êtes au courant mais
certainement discussion entre des
oligarques et des grands chefs
d'entreprise des businessman qui alors
critiquaient ouvertement le régime de
Poutine est-ce qu'on peut dire pour
autant qu'on est un tournant de
l'histoire impossible de le dire vous le
savez bien peut-être oui mais ce qui
importe ce qui est notable ce sont les
échos qui nous proviennent encore une
fois de ce cette ce système intérieur on
peut pas dire si Vladimir Poutine va
être déboulonné ou pas mais il existe
bien une fragilisation en tout cas des
signaux d'affaiblissement de son régime
et la conclusion du professeur d'arvard
il y a quand je laisse dans L'Express et
d'ailleurs intéressant il demande aux
Occidentaux de préparer dès aujourd'hui
la prépoutine et aussi de réfléchir à
qui pourrait incarner l'alternative mais
de penser également à la future Russie
comme un potentiel partenaire et donc
repenser tout système de sanction alors
il y a beaucoup de thèmes à aborder et
les minutes ont filé très vite mais je
lui interrompt on va pas revenir sur le
caprigogène on l'a beaucoup parlé sur ce
plateau ce chaos cette violence dans les
dans les grandes villes ramenées par
certains soldats de retours du front
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire c'est le
c'est le retour c'est la monnaie de sa
pièce les régimes autocratiques on porte
souvent en eux-mêmes les gènes leur
propre destruction en voulant détruire
l'Ukraine j'abonde complètement dans le
sens de ce qui a été dit précédemment
symboliquement biologiquement quasiment
et surtout politiquement bien sûr
finalement la Russie qui nous dit que
les Ukrainiens sont des Russes donc il
veut détruire apparemment une partie des
Russes finalement il détruit son propre
régime il n'y aurait pas de retour de
soldats traumatisés et ultra-violant
s'il n'y avait pas de guerre en Ukraine
il n'y aurait pas de millise Wagner s'il
n'y avait pas de d'accord secret sur
fond de corruption avec d'autres pays
autocratiques où on déploie la milice
Wagner il n'y aurait pas non plus de
contestation des oligarques s'il y avait
de la transparence dans les marchés
publics il n'y aurait pas de
contestation sociale s'il y avait les
moyens politiques d'expression au sein
de la société il n'y aurait pas de
mouvement de contestation s'il y avait
du journalisme autorisé donc vous
comprenez bien du journalisme disons
transparent donc tout ça concourt en
fait à affaiblir son propre régime
juste pour compléter parce que je trouve
ça extrêmement juste que ce que vous me
dire c'est qu'à à la fin ces armes vont
être retournées contre la Russie la
Fédération de Russie elle-même il y a
quelques jours on a vu sur Arte
magnifique documentaire sur les milices
Wagner et leurs deux buts lors de la
première invasion de l'Ukraine en 2014
c'est les vrais débute sont là et voyez
aujourd'hui 10 ans après nous sommes à
voir et gagner Prigogine en tant que
figure politique qui pourra peut-être un
jour menacer le régime vous voyez c'est
ça se passe devant nos yeux bon je vous
interrompre d'ailleurs on fera une
émission concernant une partie
d'émission Miss Wagner dans quelques
jours juste pour conclure sur les
conséquences juridiques parce que je
trouve que c'est très vraiment important
de vous entendre là-dessus on parle
beaucoup de la lumière Poutine mais il y
a pas que lui
des oligarques des militaires qui
l'entourent pourront aussi être jugés
effectivement alors déjà les simples
soldats vont être jugés ils ont commencé
à l'être en Ukraine donc ils pourront
être jugés leurs officiers aussi mais
moi c'est vrai que ce qui m'intéresse
spécifiquement ce sont les plus hauts
responsables parce que la chaîne de
commandement est tellement opaque en
Russie que c'est toujours difficile de
relier les plus hauts commandant aux
actes aux dieux qui sont commis donc là
l'idée c'est pour ça que c'est de juger
pour crime d'agression les plus hauts
responsables parce que là l'épreuve on
les a il suffit de relier leur
participation à l'initiative le
déclenchement la préparation de la
guerre et ça on peut le faire alors
évidemment pour Vladimir Poutine mais
aussi si on en croit la Constitution il
faudra qu'il prouve le contraire pour le
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
défense le Premier ministre les
financeurs les plus hauts responsables
de l'armée on a quand même un certain
nombre de personnes qui lui seront jugés
et donc la conséquence d'un
déboulonnement éventuel de Vladimir
Poutine ou d'une trahison interne ce son
jugement que ce soit par une remise de
par les autorités russes à une
juridiction internationale ou bien par
la levée de son immunité pour qu'il
puisse être juger ailleurs donc
attention on a toujours pensé que
c'était impossible pour d'autres chefs
d'État moi je pense que c'est possible
et que ce sera possible merci beaucoup
merci à tous Mathilde figuier votre
livre peut-on juger Poutine on est au
cœur de ce du débat publié aux éditions
Albin Michel Julien Theron la stratégie
non la stratégie du désordre c'était un
livre ancien là vous venez de publier Le
Pacte des autocrates chez Robert Lafont
merci encore d'avoir participé à ce
débat à bientôt sur sur public